[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on est déjà demain
quel invitation moi ce que j'ai choisi
d'en comprendre c'est que dans nos
présents sont en germe nos demain à
partir de là la question que je me pose
c'est à quel pouces est ce que j'accorde
mon attention aujourd'hui quel futur je
choisis de faire grandir
aujourd'hui pour demain il ya 50 ans
l'humanité marché sur la lune
c'était seulement huit ans après que
john kennedy en est fixé l'objectif il
ya 50 ans pour la première fois nous
avons vu la terre depuis l'espace
nous avons pris conscience de la
singularité de notre petite maison bleue
plein de vie suspendue dans le vide de
l'univers pourtant ça n'a pas suffi à
faire de nous de digne habitants de la
terre pour ma part je vais pas vous
parler ici de justice climatique ou de
biodiversité mais une chose est sûre
c'est que aujourd'hui plus que jamais
nous sommes hauteur de nos futures et
pour ma part je crois profondément en
l'humanité en notre capacité créatrice
mais j'ai aussi des doutes car nous ne
sommes toujours pas dans les starting
blocks prêts à engager ce nécessaire
changement de trajectoire
et si en 2019
cinquante ans après avoir marché sur la
lune nous décidions de rester sur terre
de devenir véritablement des terrienne
et des terriens ça c'est un futur auquel
j'ai envie de contribuer et ce qui me
réjouit en ce moment c'est que nous
sommes de plus en plus nombreux à avoir
conscience que nous allons dans le mur
nous savons nous voyons nous le
ressentons et pour certains nous le
vivons déjà cette situation ce contexte
que nous nous sommes créées on peut le
représenter
métaphoriquement sous la forme d'un
anthony
à la mauvaise nouvelle on voit tout de
suite c'est que au fur et à mesure où le
temps passe notre marge de manoeuve
diminue mais on peut aussi se demander
mais comment se fait-il que notre marge
de manoeuvre diminue malgré nos progrès
nos innovations nos solutions pour faire
plus efficaces et moins polluants
et si c'était tout simplement parce que
nous n'avons pas compris les règles du
jeu du système terre alors là cela ouvre
de nouveaux horizons
on comprend tout de suite que dans
n'importe quel jeu si on n'a pas compris
la règle du jeu
ça va être difficile de gagner enfin
plutôt de jouer car au jeu du vivant
l'objectif n'est pas de gagner c'est de
pouvoir continuer à jouer c'est ça le
développement durable moi j'ai fait mon
changement de paradigme c'était en 2001
je faisais de la recherche en gestion et
traitement des déchets industriels
j'avoue après cinq années j'en avais
ras-le-bol des déchets et puis surtout
j'ai pris conscience que peut-être
chercher des solutions en bout de chaîne
c'est peut-être pas la meilleure des
stratégies que je pouvais me poser
d'autres questions pourquoi est ce qu'il
ya des déchets est il possible de faire
autrement
est il possible d'inventer d'autres
réponses à nos besoins qui n'implique
pas systématiquement de générer des
déchets et c'est comme ça que je suis
tombé dans la marmite du développement
durable une vraie révolution
copernicienne avec plein de questions
l'étape question dont je n'avais pas la
réponse immédiate mais qui je le sentais
s'inscrit mais beaucoup plus dans les
logiques du vivant alors si je reviens à
la métaphore de l'entonnoir peut-être
que la question qui nous est posée c'est
et si tous les enjeux auxquels nous
sommes confrontés aujourd'hui étaient
juste des erreurs de conception des
erreurs de design de mauvais choix de
développement que nous avons fait pour
répondre certes à nos besoins mais en
n'ayant pas compris les règles du jeu du
système terre
alors le futur que nous pouvons nous
souhaiter c'est la sortie de l'entonnoir
c'est ce moment nous allons retrouver un
équilibre entre nos besoins et les
limites planétaires et là je parle pas
de sur vie 1
moi je parle de vivre pleinement notre
potentiel d'humanité car nous ne sommes
pas encore là et ça ça pourrait être une
véritable actualisation de la définition
du progrès et au delà comme vous le
voyez la marge manoeuvre peut s'ouvrir à
nouveau et ça c'est lié à la capacité
régénérative de la nature et de
nouvelles économies et pour cela il ne
faut pas passer trop de soleil
irréversible en tout cas ce qui est
évident et si c'est que les stratégies
d'adaptation ne seront pas suffisantes
en plus je ne sais pas pour vous mais je
trouve que la perspective de devoir
s'adapter à un monde dans lequel la
marge de manoeuvre diminue n'a rien de
stimulant
moi j'ai plutôt envie de contribuer à
l'émergence de sociétés à prospérité
renouveler et c'est ça qui me réjouit
aussi en ce moment c'est que nous sommes
de plus en plus nombreux à percevoir et
à entrevoir ses possibles demain chacun
d'entre nous à un bout de la solution
alors ce que j'ai envie de faire ici
c'est juste de partager avec vous
quelques uns de ses repères que j'ai
collecté au fil des années et qui m'aide
à donner corps à ces nouveaux paradigmes
mon premier repère c'est la manière dont
nous représentons au développement
durable images que l'on voit le plus
souvent c'est celle sous la forme de
trois cercles interconnectés le défaut
de cette représentation
c'est qu'elle est hors sol et puis
surtout elle nous laisse croire que nous
pouvons choisir le degré auquel nous
allons prendre en compte la dimension
sociale ou environnementale
c'est bien ce que nous avons fait
pendant toutes ces années
une autre présentation plus proche de la
réalité
c'est celle sous la forme de trois
cercles concentriques
elle nous rappelle en un clin d'oeil
qu'il n'y a pas de société humaine sans
planétaire
et qu'il n'ya pas d'activités
économiques sang humain alors bien sûr
c'est très schématique mais à l'heure où
il ya beaucoup d'invitations voir
d'injonctions à renouveler nos
imaginaires c'est une manière simple de
nous rappeler notre interdépendance au
système terre et aux vivants et aussi de
redonner du sens à nos activités
économiques
vous le voyez comme moi en fonction de
la représentation à partir de laquelle
je choisi de regarder le monde
nous allons nous poser des questions
différentes et nous allons développer
des solutions différentes
mon deuxième repères c'est la différence
entre compliquée et complexe
souvent on utilise ces mots l'un pour
l'autre
pourtant ils représentent des mondes
bien différents un problème compliqué
c'est un problème dans la résolution m'a
demandé de l' expertise mais une fois
vous avez compris comment ça marche
les résultats sont reproductibles et
vous pouvez mettre en place un plan une
procédure
alors si je force le trait finalement
allé sur la lune
c'est l'expression d'une société qui
maîtrise le compliqué mais en fait c'est
juste un gros calculs un problème
complexe
c'est différent les liens de cause à
effet ne font sens que rétrospectivement
et ça c'est lié à la multiplicité des
paramètres et de leurs interactions et
donc les résultats sont difficilement
prédictible et encore moins
reproductibles et donc interagir avec le
vivant pour répondre à nos besoins
humains c'est complexe
cela nous demande de penser de manière
différente et d'agir de manière
différente donc là l'enjeu n'est pas
tellement de changer de paradigme
mais c'est plus c'est effectivement de
se dire ok je suis en face de telles
situations
est ce que je mets ma paire de lunettes
plutôt aller sur la lune ou est-ce que
je mets ma paire de lunettes rester sur
terre ça vous parle ces différents
repères vous aussi vous les voyez c'est
paradigme qui nous appellent ce moment
nous serons des terrienne et des
terriens
pour finir j'ai encore deux super
ingrédients que j'ai envie de partager
le premier c'est les règles du jeu du
système terre vous savez celle dont je
vous disais au début qu'elle nous
manquait pour pouvoir vraiment jouer au
jo du vivant ces principes nécessaires à
des sociétés durables
ils ont été développés il ya déjà trente
ans en suède
ils sont utilisés aujourd'hui par des
milliers d'organisations il en faut
encore beaucoup plus aujourd'hui pour
véritablement mener ce changement de
trajectoire dont nous avons tant besoin
ces principes ils ont été pensés comme
un langage et nous sommes tous invités à
nous en emparer pour être auteur et
acteur de nos futurs après tout nous
apprenons à marcher à chanter à lire à
écrire à compter
nous pouvons apprendre ce langage ces
règles du jeu du système terre et nous
pouvons choisir d'utiliser cette paire
de lunettes nouveau paradigme très
tendance pour guider nos choix
aujourd'hui pour demain mon deuxième
ingrédient c'est la joie alors là
attention s'agit pas d'être naïfs ou de
faire l'autruche c'est plutôt de osez
vraiment se connecter à la réalité la
situation aux et contacté la peur la
colère la tristesse que nous pouvons
très sainement ressentir ses émotions
elles ne sont pas très agréables à vivre
mais elles sont notre boussole
elles nous disent simplement que nous
devons bouger faire autrement pour
honorer ce qui est vivant en nous vous
l'aurez peut-être remarqué la joie chez
ces personnes qui sont investies dans
les mouvements zéro déchet villes en
transition alternatiba colibri il ya la
joie
il y a de la joie à reprendre la main il
ya de la joie à redevenir hauteur de son
futur de nos futurs il ya la joie à
retrouver du sens
à son quotidien à son métier à ses
engagements de parents et de citoyens se
mettre en mouvement
changer de trajectoire vers des sociétés
à prospérité renouveler ses se
reconnecter à ce qui est profondément
vivent en nous c'est prendre soin de soi
des autres et du vivant c'est choisir de
devenir terrienne était rien alors et si
pour demain nous décidions aujourd'hui
de rester sur terre
vous êtes prêts j'ai pas fini
moi je vous donne rendez-vous dans huit
ans pour célébrer notre atterrissage et
imaginé en 2040
comment nous serons fiers de raconter ce
moment à nos plus petits
et cette histoire elle commencera par il
était une fois en 2019 l'humanité choisi
de devenir terrienne merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]